[Music]
welcome to session 46 in the
world of speculative fiction series this
time
we are going to be focused on ursula k
le guins earth earthsea
trilogy which of course was expanded
into further volumes but we're going to
be focusing just on the
first three volumes so this is a talk
series that i started back in 2016.
originally we met in face-to-face
sessions at the brookfield public
library we had a lot of lively
discussions
we would pick uh authors and
texts that that had a sort of common
narrative
world so we did things like looking at
tolkien's lord of the rings
or rogers zelazny's uh chronicles of
amber things along
those sort of lines and we did ursula k
le guin
in the very first year concentrating on
her heinish novels these science fiction
novels set
out there in the galaxy this time we're
going to be revisiting
ursula k le guin and as i said focusing
on the earth sea trilogy
so they're all contained here in this
massive tone
the books of earth sea and we include
two
early short stories in there as well
that we'll talk about
in just a moment so what we're doing
this month is sort of
part of a double header we're going to
go into
the the first three uh novels in the
earth sea trilogy
and we're going to reserve the other
three main books
of earth sea for next month so
you know we're not going to have to
cover this entire thing
in one fell swoop and that will allow a
little bit of a deeper
study and discussion about what was
going on in this now
every one of these talks has been
involving several different elements we
talk about the biography
of the author we also focus a lot on the
the world building the narrative
universe
that is constructed by the author and
what its features are and what's going
on in it
inevitably that means that we get into
character
and plot and theme and other elements
but the world building
is really quite central that's why it's
worlds of speculative fiction
and then after that we would generally
talk about
a number of different philosophical
themes
that are being raised or discussed or in
some way
addressed by the
novels or short stories that we're
looking at so in the case of ursula k le
guin
for example one of these would be the
nature of
human identity so important
both in a wizard of earth sea but also
in the the two
follow-up novels as well another
key philosophical theme would be that of
the equilibrium
which is coming to some degree out of
leguin's
own study of taoism and it's woven into
the story
so we're going to talk about all of
those sorts of themes
after we get into her biography and the
world building
before that i do want to say a little
bit about
why i selected these particular works
i just recently turned 50 and
one of the things that i asked for in my
wish list which
somebody did in fact purchase for me
very nice
for them to do that was this this
omnibus
the world the books of earth see the
illustrated edition which has not only
all of the
stories and novels and also some
some great little retrospectives by
ursula k le guin
herself but also some amazing
illustrations i mean you can see the
cover art is
is quite excellent as as well and
i encountered the earthsea novels as
a middle schooler i read
ursula k le guins the beginning place
and then i i was at the waukesha library
i used to browse around in
they have these big uh you know turning
things i forget exactly what they're
called but
you've all seen them in drug stores or
bookstores and they'd have all these
books on them
and there was a a section for i think
like
you know teenage fantasy and science
fiction novels
and so i was over there and i saw these
these books and i was you know
very interested in in dragons and
wizards and things like that at that
time so i grabbed
the first one and started reading it and
it was really quite captivating
and then you know i read the the ones
that followed after that and at that
time that was basically
as much as you could get and then i
remember getting a copy of the wins 12
quarters when i was a college student
and then
you know i read a lot of other ursula k
le guin things as well
but so those were the definitive ones
for me those first
three novels you know a wizard of earthy
tombs of ottowan and the farthest shore
and this character
of of ged i i found it extraordinarily
compelling
i think at that time i didn't really
quite care as
much about the other characters quite
frankly
but i really identified with with him
and what he was what he was going
through so you know
the other thing i'll say too before we
jump into talking about ursula k le guin
and her life and biography is that
if you haven't read these these stories
you are going to find that because of
her
writing style and because of
the brevity of these novels that they're
they're fairly
easy to work your way through you could
probably read your way through any one
of the first three novels
over the course of a long day and these
would be ideal
stories to to read while you're you know
stuck doing something like in quarantine
or convalescing
or on you know for me it would be like
on a gloomy
uh kind of cold day with the windows
open and you know smell of rain in the
air
if you have a fireplace a fire lit in it
enjoying some sort of you know drink
like could be in my case coffee or if
you like
beer or a glass of wine or hot cocoa or
something like that and just curling up
and reading your way through these
novels i think that would be
almost an ideal way to do it if you
could
have a cat in your lap at the time that
might make it even
better but they're all really
wonderful novels they have definitely
stood the test of time i haven't read
the wizard of earth sea
and tombs of adawan uh until i hadn't
read them since i was a kid until
until i uh started preparing for it for
this
so they are just as good now
as they were back then and so let's jump
now
into talking about ursula kayla green
this amazing author
and the very interesting life that she
lived ursula k leguin
is an author who was very productive
lived a very long and rich life she
only died quite recently she was born in
1929 to her father albert craber and
theodora krakow and so craiger was her
original name she was born in in
berkeley california
and i'll go into a bit of why that
family background
matters but i do want to point out that
in 1938 as
a nine-year-old she writes her first
fantasy story so like many of the other
people that we've talked about
in this series she is getting an early
start
and she's she's doing what many of them
did which is
reading extensively and then taking what
she's
she's reading and sort of modeling
herself
after that in 1940
she submits a science fiction story to
astounding
is rejected so she's already learning uh
the the
the fact that it's quite difficult to
get yourself
in at least the foot in the door and
she's gonna go off you know she finishes
high school
goes off to college goes to radcliffe
and graduates with a bachelor's
and begins writing novels
in 1952 she is at columbia university
she receives her master's there
and in 1953 something rather important
is going to happen
she goes she wins a fulbright
scholarship goes to study
in france and a fulbright scholarship if
you're not aware of what these are they
are you know scholarships money set
aside
to help americans go to other places
they also bring
people here and the idea is to you know
develop
a cadre of people who have intercultural
understanding
so this is a good time to back up a
little bit and talk about
um you know the life that she lived in
berkeley so
one of the things she said in one of the
many interviews
she said there was something in the air
that her bra her father breathed as an
anthropologist
the people he knew the people who came
to the house and the things they talked
about
you could say i grew up now this is a
wonderful expression
in a house where all the doors were open
there weren't just there weren't just
weren't a lot of shut doors and no
locked ones
and that does something to a kid's mind
it gives them freedom and a kind of
security in the world okay people are
different
there's all kinds of different people
isn't that interesting
instead of another reaction possible oh
isn't that horrible so you know she's
growing up in a household
in which some of the things that we
nowadays
stress i would say at least in part of
our educational world
about tolerance and understanding and
appreciation
of difference in diversity those were
you could say the norm it doesn't mean
that
anything anybody did was automatically
good but it meant that you would judge
people
based on how they were and you would try
to understand
what was going on in their mind and so
for for a novelist especially
the kind that she's going to become this
is indeed
quite quite helpful she did go
to to berkeley high she said that there
were 3 500 kids there
and it's kind of an interesting
curiosity
she and philip k dick were there at the
same time and she says
nobody knew philip k dick i've not found
one person from berkeley high
who knew him he was an invisible
classmate
so you know it's easy to understand
they didn't run into each other now
coming back to
being in france she meets and marries
charles a le guin
there and they they eventually settle in
portland oregon so still
on the west coast and in 1961
she starts publishing short stories in
various magazines so after a number of
rejections
she finally gets some some traction and
two of the short stories that are found
in this volume
in part because they are you could say
the nucleus
of the the whole earth sea universe or
if not the nucleus at least
a seed from which they come out
two of those short stories are published
in 1964
the rule of names and the word of
unbinding both of them are dealing with
with magic
and the sort of system that's going to
be found
in earth sea that she's going to develop
and then she starts having a lot more
success in 1966 she publishes rokinon's
world and planet of exile you heard me
mention the hanish novels a little bit
earlier
those are two of the first ones 67 city
of illusions something that's in the
middle of the highness
cycle as we now call it and then in 1968
she publishes
a wizard of earthsea and nine lives and
here
i think it's good to go to what leguin
herself
had to say in the afterword to a wizard
of earthsea
and i'm going to read some of this to
you she said once upon a time
a publisher asked me if i'd write a
novel for teenagers
oh no i said no no thanks very much but
i couldn't
it was the idea of writing with a
specific audience in mind
or a specific age of reader that scared
me off i'd published
fantasy and science fiction but i was
interested in the forum itself not in
who read it or how old they were
but maybe my real novel was i'd spent so
many years writing novels
sending them to publishers and having
them come back with a dull thud on the
dorm
doormat that i had trouble comprehending
an actual publisher
actually asked me to write a book this
is sort of a surprise for her
and so you know skipping forward a
little bit she said
i thought about it the idea sank in
would writing for older kids be so
different than
just writing why despite what some
adults seem to think teenagers are fully
human
and some of them read as intensely and
keenly as if their life depended on it
sometimes maybe it does and here we
could actually have a little digression
about
you know the y a or young adult genre
which is a huge huge
market at this point in time but didn't
it did exist back then but
not to the degree that it does now
leguin is in fact
you could say rejecting that that notion
of a genre split
so she goes on and she says fantasy pure
old-fashioned fantasy not mixed with
science fiction
i like the idea all my life i've been
reading about wizards
dragons magic spells and she says back
in 1967
wizards were all more or less two merlin
gandalf right the merlin of the king
arthur stories
gandalf of the incredibly by that time
successful
lord of the rings and she says old men
peaked hats white beards but this was to
be a book for young people well
merlin and gandalf must have been young
once right
and when they were young when they were
full kids how did they learn to be
wizards
so she asked herself that question and
there was the
impetus and the core for her book and if
you think about ged
if you've read the wizard of ersie he is
kind of a screw-up at first the way that
most of us are
as kids in in his case he creates a
rift within you know the world by
by his foolishness but you know we all
create some riffs of one form or another
she goes on and and then she talks about
before i began to write the story i got
a big piece of poster board
and drew the map i drew all the islands
of earth see the archipelago the car get
lands the reaches
and i named them hovnor the great island
at the middle of the world
celador far out in the west on the
dragon's run and hurr at her
and all the rest but only as i sailed
with gad from gantt did i get to know
the islands one by one with them i first
came to roque
and the 90 i isles and oskill and
further east
even than estowel and with him i first
went to the dark dry country the place
across the wall where the dead must go
so she's telling us about her world
building process
there which we're going to get into
shortly
and then she says here we go
when a wizard of earthy came out there
had not been a book like it
it was original it was something new but
it was also conventional enough not to
frighten reviewers
it was very well received it won a
boston globe horn book award
and the fact that fantasy isn't for a
certain age but as a literature
accessible to anyone who reads that
helped too
and she goes on and she talks about the
conventionality of the story its
originality reflects its existence
and partial subversion of an accepted
recognized
tradition i i grew up with that is
the tradition of fantastic tales and
hero stories
right and she says that most of this
flood of literature was written for
adults but modernist literary ideology
shunted it to children
and kids could and did swim in it
happily as in their native element at
least until some teacher
or professor told them they had to come
out dry off and breathe modernism
ever after and so she
she's talking here about you know this
great development of earthsea as a place
where she can work out the
these these stories and so the wizard of
earth see
is coming out like we said in 68
69 the left hand of darkness major
achievement for her
wins the hugo and nebula awards the the
next year
and then um the earthsea stuff continues
1971
she brings out both the tombs of adawan
and the lathe of heaven
that's a wonderful book too if you
haven't read it you should and then
1972 she writes the farthest shore and
that's that's essentially the earth sea
trilogy wizard of usa tombs of adam on
the farthest shore
all happening within you know roughly
a five-year period
and so there's there's a good continuity
there she's also writing
some other earth-sea stories at the time
she writes an essay from elfland to
poughkeepsie which is a really wonderful
discussion of the fantasy
genre in 1973
1974 writes the dispossessed which wins
the nebula
and then shortly afterwards a hugo in 75
she also writes the wins 12
quarters a series of short stories some
of which are earth-sea stories
um in 1976 she follows this up with the
word
for world as forest another one of the
hanish novels
orcidian tales and you know it continues
on
past that 78 eye of the heron
1979 malafraina
1980 the beginning place the one i'd
mentioned reading before
1982 the compass rose so it's book after
book after book after book she's quite
fruitful
and she gives a commencement address at
mills college which is which is quite
interesting it's called the left-handed
commencement address
in 1984 she helps to found the oregon
institute of literary arts so one of the
things that's important about leguin is
she's not
a she's not an artist she's not a writer
who withdraws to her you know little
castle away from everybody
and then does her craft and then you
know doesn't engage
she actually was was you know
considerably engaged with the
literary and artistic community uh
throughout her
entire life by the the 90s we're
starting to see
adaptations of the wizard of earth see
in 1996
the bbc brings out a two-hour wizard of
earth c
uh in a radio form and then she returns
to earthsea
in in 1990 with tahanu a novel
which is going to focus on the female
heroine
of the tombs of arawan
in 1998 laguna long had a very strong
interest in taoism as a philosophy and
as a way of life
in 1998 yes 1998
she publishes a translation of the dow
to jing
on the way she's publishing a few more
things in the highness cycle four ways
to forgiveness a set of
short stories the telling and then in
2001
she publishes tales from earth from
earthsea
and then in 2002 the birthday of the
world
in 2004 the sci-fi channel
uh does an adaptation of uh
basically the first two books they call
it the legend of earth see it's later
just called earth sea
leguin when interviewed about it was a
little bit
diplomatic saying i'm not super happy
with how this has turned out but you
know you
you know she actually at one point said
it is it'd be as if you wrote the lord
of the rings and everything turned out
great in the end
which is not how things ought to be um
in 2005 the bbc once again returned to
the earth sea
and they released a six-part
dramatization
covering the entire trilogy of it
some may remember that in 2009 she was
one of the people who
resigned from the author's guild over
the digitization that google had just
begun
of books she saw the writing on the wall
of what google might turn into
and how this could be bad for authors
in 2014 she was awarded a medal for
distinguished contribution to
american letters and i should mention
that the library of congress
named her a living legend in 2000
as well um in in 2018
she'll she'll die 80 years 88 years old
at her home she'd been in poor health
for a while
and so up until the end though she was
quite active
in the internet she had a author's blog
and she would
write quite a few things on there and
answer people's questions
she was holding writing workshops there
are a number of videos out there of her
speaking
so you can really get a good flavor for
her mind and what what she was
doing one of the things that we're going
to talk about
as a key philosophical theme is feminism
and leguin
always had sort of a you know you could
call it a somewhat conflicted
relationship with feminism she didn't go
in whole hog
she said at a certain point came
literary feminism
which was both a tremendous problem and
a gift to me i had to
handle it and i wasn't sure i could
because i'm not much good on
theory go away just let me write but the
fact is i was getting stuck in my
writing
i couldn't keep pretending i was a man
and so feminism came along
at the right moment for me it said to me
hey guess what you're a woman you can
write like a woman
i saw that women don't have to write
about what men write about or write what
men think they want to read
i saw that women have whole areas of
experience men don't have and that
they're worth
writing and reading about so then i went
back and really read virginia woolf a
great author if you haven't read her
somebody you want to dig into
and read all the books the feminists
were offering to us books other women
had been writing for centuries
i saw that women can write like women
and that they can write about different
things than men why not duh it took me
years really to climb on board there was
some criticism
of the tombs of ottawa
about whether you know they had a female
protagonist but
is it really a a feminist work or not
this character arya or tenar
is in some ways she saves and is also
saved by
ged or sparrowhawk and then later on
uh you know in in the the next volume in
the series the fourth one
um uh she's t
uh to tahanu she's she's retaking up
this
theme so this gives you a sense about
the the life that that leguin lived you
know it spans
uh you know world war ii uh the cold
war all these developments that were
taking place in the 1960s
another key thing that we can actually
say about her in in terms of
literary uh matters is that she is
actually part of
the what we call the new wave of of
science fiction which was
oriented away from what was called hard
science fiction you know just
lasers and and you know basically the
the plot and a lot of space opera
and much more oriented towards looking
at things through sociological or
psychological
or even ecological in the case of dune
sorts of lenses leguin would also fit in
there as well
exploring characters and their
development looking at their
relationships
bringing in a lot of literary devices
and elements
from outside of the science fiction
sphere
and so you know is that is that going to
be present
uh in the the earthsea trilogies trilogy
i would say
not as much but they are very without
seeming so they are very literary works
they're really well crafted
so that's probably enough about her life
let's talk now about the world building
that went into earthsea and i'm going to
read a passage i don't usually do this
but i'm going to read this passage again
she says only as i sailed with ged from
gaunt did i begin to know the islands
one by one so rather than being like
tolkien where there's a creation of a
map and
also creation of languages and backstory
and all this sort of stuff
tolkien is what we call an architect in
in this sort of
world building stuff um leguin is more
like what what our george rr martin
described himself as being
a gardener where you know you plant some
things and then you see what sprouts
from it and you try to see if you can
make it work together
except in this case of course we're not
talking about a garden so much we're
talking about
an ocean that is filled with
islands at least until we get out to the
furthest
reaches right and it's centered around
a really big island and then there's all
these other islands
out there and each has its own towns
and its own approaches to things its
specializations
you could say its own its own history
there is to some degree a shared
history but the further out you get the
less the people on those other places
really
care about that that shared history and
there are specializations so
you know they're they're roque for
example is the island
of the mages where all of this teaching
of magic is going to be happening in a
systematic way
and so it's it's uh it's an island
land um we're never quite sure what lies
at the edges of the map there are places
where
the ocean kind of runs out there's the
farthest
shore as well where you can reach the
land of the dead and cross
over and then there's the kargash lands
which play such an important role
both in the very beginning of a wizard
of earth sea
because that's it's kargish raiders who
are invading
and also in the uh tombs of ottawa
which are set in the kargash lands and
le guin in her uh afterward to wizard of
earth sea
says some some things about earth sea
that i think are quite
useful to keep in mind so
she mentioned subversive elements to her
story
right so the subversive elements
included these having a brown skinned
hero she said
ged's people the archipelagons are
various shades of copper and brown
shading into black in the south and east
reaches
the light-skinned people among them have
far northern or kargish
ancestors the kargish raiders in the
first chapters are white
sarat who both as girl and woman betrays
gad is white
get his copper brown and his friend
vetch is black i was bucking the racist
tradition
of fantasy making a statement but i made
it quietly and it went almost unnoticed
she points out as well
that she had a very difficult time
getting illustrators
to make ged not lily white and this was
this is an issue too with some of the
adaptations
now another thing she says about earth
sea and then this has to do with her
world building
she said my story took off in its own
direction
away from the tradition also in the
whole matter
of what makes heroes and villains
hero tales and adventure fantasies
traditionally put the righteous hero in
a war
against unrighteous enemies which he
usually wins
this convention was and still is so
dominant it's usually taken for granted
of course a heroic fantasy is good guys
fighting bad guys a war of good against
evil we might think about tolkien's
uh books as an example but there are no
wars in earth sea
no soldiers no armies no battles none of
the militarism that came from the
arthurian saga
and other sources and that by now under
the influence of fantasy war games
has become almost obligatory i didn't
and don't think this way my mind doesn't
work in terms of war
my imagination refuses to limit all the
elements that make an adventure story
and make it exciting
danger risk challenge courage to
battlefields
a hero whose heroism consists of killing
people is uninteresting to me and i
detest the hormonal war
orgies of our visual media the
mechanical slaughter of endless
battalions of black-clad yellow-toothed
red-eyed
demons and so earth-sea
becomes a place by deliberate design
that is not just you know people
fighting against each other and having
these stories about
the wars that they're doing as a matter
of fact it's more of a
place where people are challenged by the
everyday
by the commercial by in intellect and
and learning and knowledge and things
like that
there are indeed conflicts there is
indeed fighting and there are dragons
coming in
to sometimes cause a lot of trouble and
kill people as well
there are fights there are people
drawing knives there is bloodletting
there's even kargish raiders of course
coming in and and
raiding but there isn't really this this
whole
you know everybody at war with everybody
else sort of a hobby and environment
and so that that choice early on
about what kind of what kind of plot am
i going to be working with what kind of
characters that helps to determine the
world
that earth sea is and as leguin points
out
as we follow the characters
moving from place to place to place
we find out what these these lands are
like and we find out what other peoples
are like as well
a prime example of this would be the
raft people
in the farthest shore who come to shore
every once in a while but actually live
on their own gigantic uh you know
floating
rafts cut from from trees they have
their own
culture in which the whales the great
ones are the ones who they
are following in fact they they think of
get at that time the arc
archmage as being perhaps one of those
in human form i mentioned dragons
this is a realm in which dragons exist
and the dragons are you know and to some
degree as leguin said
modeled after previous versions of
dragons but they also
have a sort of we could say unique
relationship
with the mages they they speak an old
tongue and can recognize each other they
can be incredibly dangerous you're not
supposed to look into their eyes
but they can form long-term
relationships with the
humans that that actually have magical
ability
and as it turns out the dragons are just
about as old
as earth sea they are a race
of their own the humans in earth sea
are living in a pre-industrial society
but you could say they are
quite industrious as we find out
what identifies a person in large part
is
what kind of work they're doing what
kind of productive work what kind of
healing work what kind of entertainment
what
what they they value and what they bring
forward
into the world and there's many
different types of people
to run across in this there are a number
of different
ways in which rulership works out each
island
is kind of its own thing you know we
find
that in in the farther shore for example
um
arnin is a prince of endlad and that
comes with
certain obligations and ideas
in the tombs of ottawa arha or tenar
is is a priestess and we learn about the
religion that they're in we can also say
this the
islands of earth sea were raised out of
the sea
out of the out of the earth at a certain
point in time
and then human beings began inhabiting
them along with dragons and other all
the other creatures
of the world and it's you know set in
the
far back time there are other powers
however who inhabit the world who are
neither human nor
dragon nor uh you know animal
and some of these old powers can be
quite dangerous in fact if you if you
want to get a great idea about them
reading the tombs of ottawan would be
the place to go
because there's a great discussion of
this
in there where ged is telling
um telling tenor about
what's what what she's actually been
worshiping as these old gods what she's
been
ministering to they they are not
human in origin and in some respect
they're
they're not even you know they're
they're you could say they're not
anti-life
they're definitely not pro-life in in
that as well
there's a stone that is is similarly
an example of a old
power as well um the stone
of taranon which could enslave
ged at a certain point so this is all
part of the world that we're talking
about i mentioned
magic and that that's a very important
aspect of this world
they use magic everybody from you know
actual
mages down to like you know village
witches and sorcerers
um they use a variety of different
techniques to shape things to do things
some of it is about creating illusions
some of it is about
healing people some of it is about
binding things together some of it is
is great spells that tear apart the
fabric
of reality uh ged himself sparrowhawk
does that
at one point as does the antagonist
of the farther shore cobb who
wants to live forever we'll talk about
that theme shortly as well
but magic is an incredibly important
part so for example
the dyers of of wool
on one of the islands that they go to in
the farther shore
because the magic of the world has been
draining out through
cobb's actions they're no longer able to
practice their craft and this
affects the entire island and how people
feel and how they
they interact with each other it also
creates economic
dislocations as well so what we've got
is this incredible
panorama which is never all spelled out
at once
although what's kind of cool is in this
earth sea volume
uh ursula k le guin gives a description
of
earth sea with peoples and languages
talking about the heart
the hardik lands the target lands
talking about
dragons as well languages writing
the history of the archipelago so you
can find all of those things
in there i don't need to really go into
all of that
a lot of discussions about the wizardry
i will
however before we go into the the themes
i will however talk about the dragons
very shortly from this so she tells us
story songs and stories indicate that
dragons existed before any other any
other living creature
the old heartache kennings or euphemisms
for the word dragon our firstborn eldest
elder children
the words for the firstborn child of a
family in
uh one of the languages ahad in
kargasgada are derived from hoth dragon
in the old speech which the dragons by
the way speak
so she goes on and she says
the creation of a contains no clear
references to original unity and
eventually separation of dragons and
humans
but this may be because the poem in its
presumed original form in the language
of the making dated back to a time
before the separation so the dragons
are in some way related to us and she
says
dragons are born knowing the true speech
or as ged puts it the dragon and the
speech of the dragon are one
if human beings originally shared that
innate knowledge or identity
they lost it as they lost dragon nature
so the dragons these incredibly powerful
creatures are also very old although
new ones can be born they they reproduce
and they come into the b they come into
the world already
filled with some degree of knowledge and
a capacity for
language the language that was used to
first
understand the world so that's probably
enough about this
fantastic world building let's get now
into some
philosophical themes that help flesh the
world out and
doing that we'll also talk about
characters and plots and
all of that sort of stuff as well and
remember we're restricting ourselves to
the first
three books of the earthsea trilogy
along with those two
early short stories as well
one of the first philosophical themes
that we should look at that runs
throughout the entire earth sea
trilogy and on into the other earth sea
stories
and novels and which actually starts out
in the
the two stories prior to the trilogy
is what we can call after one of those
stories the rule
of names and here we get a good
description of that
mr underhill and the story of the rule
of names seems to be you know decent
enough
wizard and he's uh by the schoolhouse
where they
are learning the rules of names and so
he stops to
to listen and um the the school teacher
is
actually asking the children questions
it's going through a sort of
catechism and this is a way in which
leguin can reveal to us
what's what's going on with names so she
says now you know the rules of names
already children there's two and they're
the same on every island in the world
what is one of them it ain't polite to
ask anyone what his name is shout
shouted a fat quick boy interrupted by a
little girl shrieking
you can't never tell your own name to
nobody my mom says
she says yes subba yes papi dear don't
screech that's right
you never ask anybody his name you never
tell
your own and then so she says now think
about our wizard why do we call him
mr underhill and they say cos he lives
under a hill and we can think about
ged a little bit later as sparrow hawk
people can go
by whatever moniker they want to or
whatever
fits them and then she asks
is that his true name and the boy says
no how do you know that it's not
because he came here all alone and so
there wasn't anyone knew his true name
so they couldn't tell us and he couldn't
and then she says very good tsuba papi
don't shout that's right even a wizard
can't tell his true name when you
children are through school and go
through the passage you'll leave your
child names behind
and keep only your true names which you
must never ask for
and never give away and now here we get
to we've
had the two rules you know never ask
never give
why why is that the case
the children were silent the sheep
bleeded gently mr underhill
answered the question because the name
is the thing
he said in his shy soft husky voice and
the true name
is the true thing to speak the name is
to control the thing
and so this is a a really central idea
everybody is given a name and the name
is in the true speech a language that is
in a certain respect
closer to the origins of things truer
than the language that everybody else is
using
and so if you know the true name
of a thing if you actually have power
you can use that power and thereby bind
that
thing and make it do what it is that you
want or destroy it or control it in some
way
and so ged early on in a wizard of
earthsea
he finds out the names or at least
how to summon various uh
creatures of the sky here we go so
he has a sister of his dead mother she
had done what was needful for him as a
baby but she had business of her own
and once he could look after himself she
paid no more heed to him
but one day when the boy was seven years
old untaught knowing nothing of the arts
and powers
that are in the world he heard his aunt
crying out words to a goat which had
jumped onto the thatch of a hut
and would not come down but it came
jumping when she cried a certain rhyme
to it
next hurting day next day hurting the
long-haired goats
dunny that's his name at the time
shouted to them the words he'd
heard not knowing their use or meaning
or what kinds of words they were
he yelled the rhyme aloud and the goats
came to him they came quickly all of
them together not making any sound
they looked at him out of the dark slot
in their yellow eyes he
laughed and shattered it again the rhyme
that gave him power
over the goats they came closer crowding
and pushing around him
all at once he felt afraid of their
thick rich horns and their strange eyes
and strange silence
he tried to get away and his aunt
realizes very quickly what's going on
he has power but he also was able to
learn and use the name
and she brings him in and you know she
says as her sister's son he'd been
nothing to her but now she looked at him
with a new
eye she praised him told him she might
teach him rhymes he would like better
such as the word that makes a snail look
out of its shell
or the name that calls a falcon down
from the sky and he says aye teach me
that name
being clear over the fright the goats
had given him the witch said to him you
will not tell that word to the other
children if i teach it to you
i promise and so she does teach it and
he learns slowly the names of all of
these different things and and brings
them down
to spend time with him so the name gives
you
a kind of power but it's a power of
knowledge it's a power of to a certain
degree intimacy
something else that we should talk about
with respect to
names is not just the importance of
power
but how the sharing of a name the
revelation of a name to another person
is a becoming vulnerable to them
a matter of trust and so
you know you can learn names by people
actually thinking you're a decent person
and trusting you
and giving you the name or there's many
other ways
of finding the names of things as well
particularly
for one who has power you could find
them written down somewhere if it's
something that's been around for a long
time you can use dark arts to discover
the names of things
you can spend time with them and perhaps
the names will come clear
as well and so what we find is that ged
which is the true name of of the
the wizard uh of earth sea right there
the guy who starts out
and you know his sparrow hawk and and
all those
dunny and all those things he will
reveal his true name to a few people
with whom he is friends we should point
out another thing as well about true
names
dragons who play some role in the
earthsea
universe and play a particularly
important role
i would say in the third one the
farthest shore
dragons speak to people and address them
by their true names there is no hiding
any of that from the dragons
they speak the true speech and they are
linguistic beings they're born
already having that language
human beings are different human beings
speak a language that reveals and
conceals
at the same time and so the rule of
names
says that we have to conceal the names
from other people and it's part of how
we live our life there's a
insider outsider discrepancy or
discordance you could say
now names
and naming play a very important role
in a number of different places i want
to go back to
that story the the rule of names because
there's a bit of a little bit of a twist
if you haven't read the story there's
going to be a bit of a spoiler here
so mr underhill has somebody coming
after him somebody who thinks that mr
underhill
may have stolen his treasure and
mr underhill didn't steal the treasure
directly
although as it turns out he has because
what happened was
a dragon came down and killed all these
people
and stole a horde and then flew off with
it
and then the the guy who tracks them
down
um says that must have been a you know
very powerful
dragon and i want that stuff back his
name is blackbeard
in this case and what he finds when he
tracks the dragon down are dragon bones
he says wow a wizard must have done this
killed the dragon taken the horde now
i'm gonna find that wizard and i'm gonna
kill him
and get my treasure back so he says that
must have been a powerful wizard and a
clever one first to kill a dragon
second to get off without leaving a
trace the lords and mages of the
archipelago couldn't track him at all
neither where he'd come from nor he'd
where he'd made off to they were about
to give off that was last spring
i have been tracking it and i
have have found it those fools of the
league couldn't find it
why not because it's not theirs it
belongs to the house of pandora
and the great emerald the star of the
horde knows its master
right so we have a wizard who is
tracking these things down
and then he says
here we go the jewel knows it's master
and i know the thief and i shall conquer
him he's a mighty wizard who could
overcome a dragon
but i am mightier do you know why
because i know his name
underhill says how did you learn it
and blackbeard grin did not answer black
magic
how else now he's talking to bert
about this and when he does find
underhill as it turns out
he does have the right name he does call
the right name
however there's a little twist a little
trick
underhill is that dragon and his name is
yavod
and the dragon consumes him the dragon
says well i'm i'm done you know hiding
or anything like that
comes out of hiding and starts eating
everybody and
it shows you that it's not enough just
to get the name right you have to also
understand the thing as well now
in the in the uh
series i don't want to go too deep into
this
um a wizard of earthsea god does a very
foolish thing
and he uses spells
which rend the the fabric of reality the
division between
life and death or light and darkness
and in doing so he lets in something
that becomes his monstrous double and
not only tries to kill him and take him
over and turn him into a being
they call it a gibbet a being of evil
which will wreak all sorts of havoc
if it's allowed to it also kills people
that are close to him
even the little pet that he has which
you know
stays around his neck and so long as ged
is running away from it this thing has
power over him
there's an offer by um the the lord
and lady of um where is this of taranon
to use the stone of tehran which
represents one of the old powers
to reveal the name of this this thing
that ged needs to fight and
ultimately conquer he tries by all sorts
of means to find the name he rejects
that offer because he knows that that
there's some treachery involved
and what we find in the end is the only
way
that get is able to have power over this
thing
is by naming it and the way that he
names it
is by giving it his own true name
because it is from him it is his double
and in doing so
he gains the power to overcome it
and thereby to banish the evil that
is taking place as his friend vetch
is along with him on this this final
you know final battle
so he says um
here we go until that moment veteran
watched him with an anxious dread he was
not sure what had happened in the dark
land
he did not know if this was get in the
boat with him and his hand had been for
hours ready to to the anchor to stave in
the boat's planking
and sink her there in mid sea rather
than carry back to the harbors of earth
see the evil thing he feared might have
taken
gad's look and form when he saw his
friend and heard him speak his doubt
vanished and he began to see the truth
that gad had neither lost nor won but
naming the shadow of his death with his
own name had made himself
whole a man who knowing his whole true
self cannot be used or possessed by any
power
other than himself and whose life is
therefore lived for life's sake and
never in the service of ruin
or pain or hatred or the dark
so the name is incredibly important to
one's
not just power but one's identity
one's reality a little bit later in the
tombs of ottawa
one of the things that we find so
important
for the female protagonists who is
there's really two protagonists of this
ged
who is attempting to steal a treasure
from the
the uh labyrinth of atuan to make
whole a a ring and find a rune
that will will set things right again
and the woman who's known as
arja the eaten one who is supposed to be
a reincarnation
of the previous priestess of the
nameless ones notice the nameless ones
right and in this case
she is finally given back a name
and her name her true name is
tenor so this represents
her being individuated her being no
longer
part of this long string of bodies that
a
priestess has happened to occupy
so that is is a particularly important
thing there's a discussion
with ged i'll come back to that in a
moment first
she she has a uh
dream uh she dreams of the souls of the
dead in the walls of the palm
painted room and she goes on these are
the souls of those not reborn the
ancient peoples and unbelievers
those who the nameless ones devour they
squatted around her in the shadows
and a faint creaking or cheaping sound
came from them now and then
one of them came up quite close to her
she was afraid at first and tried to
draw away but could not move
this one had the face of a bird not a
human face but its hair was golden
and it said in a woman's voice tenor
tenderly softly
tenor she wakes up really awake this
time
she sat up worn out by the knights
dreaming
she tells herself i am tenor not allowed
and she
shook with cold and terror and
exultation there under the open sunwash
sky
i have my name back i am tenar
this is a reassertion of her
identity when she's talking
with with ged in the labyrinth as
they're preparing to figure out what
they're going to do
there's a discussion between them and
she says um here we go
talking about these these these beings
do you truly think them dead you know
better in your heart they do not die
they are dark and undying and they hate
the light the brief
bright light of our mortality they are
immortal but they are not gods
they never were they are not worth the
worship of any human soul
what have they ever given you tinar
nothing she whispered
they have nothing to give they have no
power of making
all their power is to darken and destroy
they cannot leave this place they
are this place and it should be left to
them they should not be denied or
forgotten but neither should they be
worshipped
the earth is beautiful and bright and
kindly but that is not all the earth is
also terrible
and dark and cruel and so he goes on
and he says there are there are places
made in the world where darkness
gathers places given holy over to the
ones who we call
nameless the ancient and holy powers of
the earth before the light the powers of
the dark
of ruin of madness the nameless ones are
are
they say that the nameless ones are dead
only a lost soul lost to truth could
believe it they exist
but they are not your masters they never
were you are free tenor you are
taught to be a slave but you have broken
free
and she says to him how is it that you
know my name
he says knowing names is my job my art
to weave the magic of a thing you see
one must find its true name out
in my land we keep our true names hidden
all our lives long
from all but those whom we trust utterly
for there is great power
and great peril in a name once at the
beginning of time when segue raised the
aisles of earth sea from the ocean deeps
all things bore their own true names and
all doing of magic all wizardry hangs
upon the knowledge
the relearning the remembering of that
true and ancient language
of the making so this
is is another important point not only
does everything have a name there are
also things that don't have names that
we'll never discover the names for
they may indeed have names that are so
hidden that we can't we can't grasp them
he he talks in another place and i
forget exactly which story it's in
about being able to control portions of
the sea
but each part of the sea might have its
own name and the wizard or mage
or or whoever would have to spend time
discovering that
the last one that i'll mention is in
another early story
the
here we go the word of unbinding
the protagonist in it who
prefigures ged fighting with cobb in the
farthest shore
there is a wizard vol whose magic
is is strong and who has been vol the
fell
is more wizard but less than man who
passed from island island of the outer
reach undoing the works of the ancients
enslaving men
cutting forests spoiling fields sealing
in underground tombs
any wizard or mage who tried to combat
him so the protagonist in this
is a wizard festen who is sealed in one
of these underground
tombs and he decides what i'm going to
do
is um here we go
if i'm wrong men will think i was a
coward turning his head a little to the
side he closed his eyes
took a last deep breath and whispered
the word of unbinding
which is only spoken once this is not
transformation he was not
changed his body the clever hands the
eyes you like to look
on trees and streams lay unchanged only
still perfectly still and full of cold
but the walls were gone
he goes to a place of the dead
in life he had great power so here he
did not forget
like a candle flame he moved in the
darkness of the wider land
and remembering he called out his
enemy's name
vole called unable to withstand
vol came towards him fest and approached
and the other coward and screamed as if
burnt
festen followed when he fled followed
him close a long way they went over dry
lava flows
there's a long description here and
they're in a land where nothing
changes the full shadow is forced
to enter a dry stream bed
vol coward stooped and entered into the
open mouth of his own dead body at once
the course
vanished unmarked stained the dry
boulders gleamed in starlight
fest and stood for a while then slowly
sat down on the great rocks
to rest so by again using the name
and by making a great sacrifice he's
able to put an end to a
great evil so that's probably enough
about this particular theme which is a
very
interesting one is it not a second
very important theme of this earthy
trilogy
is a literary theme but also a
philosophical theme
and it is of learning and developing
into your identity as a person so we
talk about
coming of age novels and a wizard of
earth see
really is a coming-of-age novel isn't it
it's about this guy who starts out at
seven years old
you know on some you know rather distant
kind of provincial
island um finding out that he has some
talent
you know working with his aunt who gives
him some things
eventually working with a mage on the
island
who's actually studied at roke and then
being
sent to roque to
learn further and become a genuine mage
there's some other things happening
along the way the repulsion
of the kargish invaders right all of
these things are sort of standard
elements you know in moving from one
thing to the next to the next to the
next
but there's something else that happens
along the way
for ged or sparrowhawk
which is that he'll he allows something
in by
wanting to take on too great power and
doing so in response to
foolish uh provocations in in one case
by the
the girl uh on on the island in the
other case
by this other student mage jasper
who he has a rivalry with and in both
cases he tries to take on
more power than he ought to and so it's
it's in some respects a perennial
problem is it not of the talented
that when you start out and you really
haven't learned that much there's a
tendency to think that you are
more capable than you are and especially
if you haven't managed your emotions
well you can't tell
when people are goading you into
foolishness or
um you know seducing you in certain ways
and so ged ends up allowing something to
come into this
world of earth sea that shouldn't be
there
an element of darkness
a being of evil something parasitic
something bad something non-life
and it winds up becoming the main
antagonist of the entire wizard of
earthsea
once he lets this in at rock
and you know they have to undo the
damage that's been done
he winds up uh you know being grievously
hurt and has to go on on a mission
he's sort of sent away after having some
learning
to assume his role as a mage and it's
sort of like being sent to the
proverbial uh alaskan weather station in
the army they want to get you out of
there
now it's not quite so malicious as that
but what we find that he ends up doing
is
in the process um dealing with dragons
and it's very
interesting the the place that he's sent
to is being troubled by these dragons
and he's less afraid of these dragons
than he is
of this shadow that could destroy him
and create so much trouble
for everybody in the in the world if
it's able to possess him because it will
be possessing
a mage and thereby using that power for
evil
what happens in the story we have a ged
who is at first fleeing from this this
evil being
unable to face it unable to deal with it
and then eventually he finds out that if
he does turn and face it
although it's going to be difficult now
it becomes
a different sort of chase he is running
after it
and he literally chases it to the ends
of the earth or the sea of the earth
in the end by bringing his friend vetch
along
and the way in which he's able to
overcome it
is by essentially embracing it
and giving it his own name it is his
shadow
and once he can integrate that he is
able to overcome it
and to leave it behind well this is a
coming of age story it is a finding out
who you are
and in the case of gad you could say
what he finds out about himself
is that he has a rare amount of talent
and he doesn't have
at the time of his life he doesn't have
the emotional maturity
or the the you know the other kinds of
maturity and learning
to be able to handle it and he messes
things up terribly
and then has to try to set them right
and a lot of
people get hurt and damaged along the
way
so he finishes the book a older and
smarter
young man than he began it and then we
get to the tombs of ottawa
which doesn't begin with ged it begins
with
arya who the eaten one this girl
who is supposed to be the reincarnation
of the um
the god or not the goddess the the
priestess right um we begin with with
this uh her being taken
the child uh who is identified
as it here we go um let the nameless
ones behold the girl given to them who
is verily the one born
ever nameless let them accept her life
in the years of her life until her death
which is also theirs
let them find her acceptable let her be
eaten
and so she becomes this person who's
important although the cult is less and
less
looked to by the kargish kings who want
to establish themselves
as priests as well and she is
in the midst of all of these trainings
and rituals and and things like that
and she finds out that the service of
these
nameless ones has certain benefits but
it also has certain costs and so she is
identified
with this role she doesn't know who she
is she's been taken
from her family
it's through her interaction with ged
who is there to steal a half of
of a ring from the the temple he has the
other half
that she is able to acquire
a full understanding of who she is she's
she's buying into this my role is who i
am i am the eaten one
and then she discovers her true name
and her identity and chooses and this is
where it becomes very important
she has a choice that she has to make is
she going to stay is she going to
allow ged to die is she going to kill
him herself
she could do any of these things or is
she going to escape
away from atawan and
betray the very deities
not quite gods but rather powers of the
earth
who are in control of of these these
tombs
and she chooses that and in doing so she
is leaving behind so much of her old
identity
and she is moving forward into assuming
a new identity
get is a helper in that and a companion
but she is the one who has to make the
choice
so this is also a coming of age story
get is older than her
she is essentially a teenager
making this decision about where she's
going to go
and leaving her training leaving her
people leaving her land behind leaving
the the
nameless ones behind for the wider
the wider archipelago of earthsea
in the third book we have yet another
character
aaron a young man who is prince of
enlard
and he comes bearing some information
to to rock the archmage
ged is there a sparrow hawk of course
right we don't want to always reveal his
true name
and uh there have been all these reports
that
magic is no longer working as it should
be
and it's causing all sorts of other
problems throughout these these lands
the further out that you get
the more it seems like magic is dripping
or
being drained out of the world and along
with it people's competence
and the ways of of living that people
have
so aaron is there and he's at the
beginning he's very
star struck we could say right i think
it would be good to to look at the
description that is given at the start
this is a a case of
a young man who has heard so much
about this this great
wizard right so he comes in
and gives his his report
there we go i need to get a little bit
further
into it um
ah you are the son of the prince of
england and the endlet as the archmage
said heir of the principality of morad
there's no older heritage in all
earthsea none fair i've seen the
orchards of en lot in the spring
and the golden roofs of bar of barilla
how are you called
i am called aaron that would be a word
in the dialect of your land what is it
in our common speech the boy said
sword the archmage nodded there was
silence again and the boy said not
boldly but without timidity
i had thought the archmage knew all
languages the man shook his head
watching the fountain and all names all
names
only segue who spoke the first word
raising up the isles from the deep sea
knew all names to be sure if i needed to
know your true name i would know it but
there's no need
aaron i will call you and i am
sparrowhawk then he talks with him for a
while
and what we see is a boy who is
very taken by a sparrowhawk
and you know sort of things like this is
my hero you know
i don't have any magical talent my dad
does i wish i did because then i could
study here
with this guy and that's where he begins
and then they go through
all of these adventures really engaging
in something almost like
a detective story for a while and
at one point aaron saves uh ged's life
by the the actions that he takes and
they even wind up
in a place where aaron begins to
doubt ged and think that maybe he isn't
quite so great
as as he's been cracked up to be
and this is like learning about the this
is the
the young person who's learning about
that heroes
are human and arising to a certain level
of
heroism their self ged could not have
won against cobb solely by his own
powers
he needs aaron to get him through it
and by the end aaron has again
matured into a person he knows who he is
by having left some things behind and by
having gained some other things now all
of this pertains to identity
the identity of these these characters
we could also talk about the identity of
other beings that remains more or less
the same
you know the ancient uh mage organ
in in gant you know remains about the
same
um the dragons of course
they don't mature other than growing
bigger and bigger and bigger
they already are born knowing the the
true speech
and knowing who they are um so
the identity of those creatures is
something quite different than humans
we go through a developmental process
and that is what i would say the first
three books
are in significant part about we have
three
main characters get is a main character
through all of it but then we also have
these
other two as well a third
important theme of course in these works
is
how magic works and is this a
philosophical theme
i think we can say that it is because
it's there's a metaphysics
involved here we've already talked about
the the role that naming plays
but we can also talk about the fact that
there's all different ways in which
magic plays out we have magical beings
like the dragons of course
and then we have human beings who have
some sort of talent or capacity
more than others and they're not all
wizards they're not all witches as a
matter of fact
some of them are crafts people like the
dyers
whose magic goes away from them leaving
them bereft and unable to really make
the wonderful
beautiful cloths that they were
making before using magic so magic
is an integral part of the
existence of human beings it's expected
that that on each island there will be
at least one wizard
however you know bad at their craft who
can at least like patch boats together
and heal people there are a lot of women
who are also practicing
magic one of the things that that leguin
uh you know thought about later and took
a bit of heat from from feminists
was that magic was primarily in its
higher form
a male thing whereas women were were not
practicing it
uh at such a high degree in what you
know the earth see trilogy
although of course who recognizes
uh sparrowhawk or ged's talent it's his
aunt
right who is a magic
working woman on the isle of of gaunt
and magic can come in a number of
different
forms at the the aisle of rock they have
these masters who teach the different
forms
each of which has a different way of
arranging things
and getting the students to do things
there are also spells written down
that one can find and then use and
recite
sometimes with bad effects like what
what ged does
as he lets this evil being
in and you can also say that they're you
know the magic of things
is in a certain way an integration
with the rest of the world so
the way things work organically magic
taps into that and this is where we get
to some
other really important not just
metaphysical but we could say
ethical ideas as well and this is where
leguin's interest in
not just but i would say primarily
taoism
plays a big role as well so there's this
talk of
an equilibrium about things needing to
be balanced out
this is part of why ged does not just
use magic
all the time to do whatever he wants for
example to move his boat or
things like that he saves his power and
there's this idea that you shouldn't be
using it
without exercising some forethought
without
you know making sure that the things
that you're doing
fit so magic there's a temptation to use
magic
just to control to display power
to say crush enemies or to do
the things that you want make a buck but
that would be upsetting the
the equilibrium that's not the best way
to use
magic and here we could actually bring
in although it's not completely
connected with this
a taoist concept of non-action way
of of doing in some respect as little as
possible but doing the right thing at
the right time to steer things
in the right direction what we can say
about the first and the third book
is that there is a vast
imbalance taking place in both of them
in the one case it's happening
through ged and it affects him and those
close to him
and it also threatens the rest of the
world because we there's this
this being that's allowed in a a
non-being a anti-life
a darkness a shadow right and if it
possesses him
it will turn him into a gibbeth which
then will have all the powers that he
has
and go and wreak havoc and peril on the
land
there's also in the um
early story
the the the word of unbinding
right this character who
is called vol vol uh the fell
who is is doing all of these horrible
things
across earth sea that would be another
example
of somebody who's using magic and doing
so
in in a wicked and damaging
way right upsetting again the
equilibrium which has to be set right by
this guy
festen then in the third one
in the novel involving ged and
involving aaron
what we have is a former classmate of
god who he knows
cobb who is upsetting things on a much
greater level so that to the degree
that cobb is able to try to make himself
into something like a
you know a warlock and a king all in one
something almost like a god
and he's also leeching all the magic out
of
earth sea and turning even the dragons
into mere beasts
unable to speak unable to know
themselves
just reacting on an animal level
this is a very important uh
transformation and concept there
there's always this possibility we could
say in the tombs of ottowan
and also in wizard of earthsea there are
these old powers
that are not human and not dragon and
not and not
really helpful for us may be worshipped
or manipulated by people
this stone that that's found in one
place the nameless ones in the tombs of
atlan in the labyrinth
and all of all of that area and they are
you can call them evil if you want to
but they don't they don't
go beyond where they currently are
although the the uh
manipulators of the stone um want to the
stone of tehran want to use ged in order
to expand their their range
in the case of cobb there is an attempt
to
in in some respect devour or take over
the world
to turn everything into what it is that
that he wants
and if we think about the reason behind
this
one of the things that comes very clear
in
um the farthest shore the farthest shore
is
the entrance into the land of the dead
where nothing changes and the dead
exists and you can cross over
and then you probably can't cross back
so cobb has died
but he's come back from that and in
doing so he's disrupted things
across the entire world
that has to be set right that has to be
fixed in some way
and that is exactly what what ged and
aaron are doing in the story at great
cost to themselves and
at great cost to the dragon uh who has
to
well dragons actually who sacrificed
themselves
so this is a really important
idea that magic isn't just something fun
to play around with
or you know this epic struggle between
white magic and black magic or anything
like that
it's a much more complex conception that
leguin has and it can be
used well when it's integrated with the
rest of the
let's call it a system and it can be
used badly
when particularly with human beings
they use it for ends that we don't we
can't even just call it
selfish ends but let's call them
self-aggrandizing ends or or self
uh prioritizing ends in this case in the
case of cobb
to avoid dealing with death
and this this drive for that things do
have to remain
in their existence can be
deleterious for the rest of
the creation and that's that's where
magic
is really coming in and working in this
this
this
set of stories
we've talked about three important
philosophical themes found in the earth
sea
trilogy contained in the books of earth
see this this wonderful
omnibus edition and next month we're
going to be
continuing to talk about some of these
themes and introducing new ones
as we go on to read the other earthsea
books and discuss them
we can also talk about more themes for
those who want to join me
after the premiere of this video in the
video conferencing
session but i'm going to leave you with
two other micro themes we'll call them
that are both discussed here
in the farthest shore within the space
of
two pages so in the first one
it has to do with action and identity
and there's a really wonderful
discussion here and this is how you know
ursula k le guin
has a very philosophical approach to
things i would say
like you know other authors that are
great thinkers like philip k
dick dostoevsky this is this is really
quite wonderful so she says or she has
sparrowhawk say this
[Music]
i've been pretending that i am free that
there's nothing wrong in the world that
i'm not archmage not even sorcerer
that i'm hawk of tamir without
responsibilities or privileges owing
nothing to anyone
he stopped and after a while went on i
was talking to aaron
try to choose carefully aaron when the
great choices must be made
when i was young i had to choose between
the life of being
and the life of doing and i leapt at the
ladder like a trout to a fly
but each deed you do each act binds you
to itself
and to its consequences and makes you
act again and yet again
then very seldom do you come upon a
space a time like this
between act and act when you may stop
and simply be
or wonder who after all you are
how could such a man thought aaron be in
doubt as to who and what he was
he had believed such doubts were
reserved for the young who had not yet
done anything
the boat rocked in the great cool
darkness that's why i like the sea
said sparrowhawk's voice in the darkness
aaron understood him but his own
thoughts ran ahead
as they'd been doing all these three
days and nights to their quest the aim
of their sailing
and since his companion was in a mood to
talk he asked do you think we will find
what we seek in hort town
and it goes on from there but this this
great lesson about
when we act when we decide we bind
ourselves to those
actions and they compel us to act and
act
and act but there arrive places and
times
where we can we can pause for a bit and
we can then think about
am i doing the right thing am i reacting
in ways that are
bad or foolish am i
listening to the right voices and the
the notion of the sea
providing an an opportunity to get
things right you might say by
using what rayna maria rilka calls
solitude
is a prime example of this the second
one that i want to leave you with
um is a discussion about dragons
sparrowhack says the dragons are
avaricious insatiable treacherous
without pity without remorse
but are they evil who am i to judge the
acts of dragons
they are wiser than men are it is with
them as with dreams aaron we men dream
dreams we work magic we do good we do
evil
the dragons do not dream they are dreams
they do not work magic
it is their substance their being they
do not
they do not do they are
so this is quite an interesting idea
is it not of beings who their full
nature would be
there in pure actuality
dragons he says just to reiterate this
the dragons do not dream they are dreams
isn't that a wonderful phrase so on that
we'll close out for those who've been uh
watching this in the premiere
you're welcome to join us afterwards for
some video conferencing and further
discussion of this
those who are watching this after the
premiere
we will be doing another
attack or delving into earthsea
next month and you can certainly leave
whatever you want to say
in the comments and continue the
discussion that way
this is again the end of
session 46 of the worlds of speculative
fiction glad you could join me for this
[Music]
you